on our top ten pentakill video which you
can watch right here
we received a comment asking us to do
the top ten best solo killed so as
requested here are the top 10 best
fulfills of all time and read a legend
kicking off the list is westdoor solo
kill a faker his predictive flash to
secure the kill is absolutely amazing
and the fact that he walks away from the
fight even more so gives flash was still
up so he was waiting there were two
conditions he was waiting for 1/5 + as
he concludes him afterwards - he gets
low enough that they could kill him
during the consideration and we have
some Wow we're going to get killed we're
still follows the flash Oh lemon is
chasing and rest'll wins the 1v1 at
number 9 we have Ackerman's explosive
outplay against Sarah we dangerous to a
team doing it and I was just a big - -
there
oh oh I was no way what a play it just
completely outplayed saris flashing into
the number eight spot is easy who's
petrifying kill against her Oh a perfect
Cassiopeia ultimate close out by a max
range noxious blast make this play a
serious display of skill whoa glass off
on ocurro vbeaute coming in he pops a
knife even enough easyhoon oh did you
get him to poison ticking oh he doesn't
get the seal for the current and the
kill goes to easyhoon who is this guy
our seven spot goes to subsidence
godlike performance against Baker when
he pulls off not one but two solo kills
against the goat at Emma sighs into the
jungle not as fruitful that there's a
Jeff bar coming in and will it be enough
to pull the ignite
[Applause]
again against an aggressive pick making
team vacay each to shuriken the knock up
is interrupted and feather than
materializes ignite 30 to 1 he was in a
cave shuriken tossing in at number 6 is
TSM Pearson and his first blood solo
kill against maple W now you're waiting
for when the super person will do in
this trade he's going in boys took the
tower hit there is maple don't sing the
deathlok from the side really well
played out by Buicks and maybe a miss
flavor from maple side of a bull got
greedy monster drops the hammer on hooni
in our number 5 play quite possibly one
of the cleanest chains done solo kills
you'll ever see
Wow yeah I mean oh and he stopped to get
route Eliza Moody right now a gadget
slave stunning of dear Lord tosser ashes
Unni number four on the list is X heck a
famous 1v1 against da day during the
2014 World Championship group stage when
assassins clash it's always flashy but
Peggy's clutch factor here takes this
play to another level which is creative
force thought is gone got a huge
brutalizer
it's all about fight it fight that's not
going down what is it going to be enough
sunny it's gonna be a make it pop see
not enough to fit each of either the
best just enough to get paper they kill
double lifts insane 1v1 out play against
mega zero rat-a-tat-tat its way into
number 3 7 kill Riven clearly no problem
for double lift mechanics double if
these that runs the heck away from the
turbo rocket boots mega zero he puts the
slow down can he win this duel gets
knocked up into the air still trying to
run mega pop ability it's going to be
the self in from devilish who he Jukes
it will negate gosh it goes in back for
the fight I was going to be enough for
Dublin superior who gets one shot in
there so win / so it's not going to be
enough double it gets the duel it's the
victory nice stick up there doublelift
hashtag twitch mechanics because he
can't play vain
that was awesome the way he juked out
make it zero in that fight in the
ultimate game of lambs respite chicken
Miki's nail-biting 1v1 against score
grabs the second spot on our list trying
to pop away they root him in oh the
wildcards almost taking down the
lissandra and score getting locked up at
the flashing and Frey catch the Twisted
Fate one more hit ought to do it but the
gold card is drawn score just trying to
wait it out to get on oh there's no one
here to back him up he throws out the
cold card
bell rings doing a lot of damage scores
still doesn't that language is quite
available though nice Sonya is coming
across the minions chipping them down
glances Mike comes down it's going to be
a battle of who gets the first hit who's
it going to be it's going to be Mickey
coming out on top our number one spot on
the list goes to none other than the
legendary faker versus Ryu 1v1 could it
really have been anything else like even
though I only have a bat on the floor I
think exhibit Beto faker may be a
totally your death art prize to clean it
up for you oh look at the quest like in
the boat thank you what was that
think it was a human way that she wasn't
I can't pull anything artist oh yeah
actually what that tool I can't win a
now Telecom I'm Sergeant issue the Katie
full explain those were our picks for
the top 10 best solo skills of all time
in League of Legends what is your
favorite 1v1 let us know in the comment
section below
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button